PROFESSOR: Just as truth tables
provide a simple, direct way
to define the meanings of
the individual propositional
connectives or
propositional operators,
they also provide
a methodical way
to understand the
behavior of formulas,
and in particular whether
two formulas are equivalent
or whether a formula is valid,
meaning that it's always true.
So let's take a look at that.
To being with, if I'm thinking
about a propositional formula
that's a composite
one that's built out
of lots of more
atomic, primitive ones,
then in order to figure out
the value of the whole thing,
I need to know the values of
the individual components.
So if we think of a formula
involving P's and Q's and R's
that are true/false value
propositional variables,
then I need a truth
assignment to know
the values of those
variables, in order
to know whether or not the
formula is true or false.
So in computer science
jargon, this process
of assigning values to variables
is called an environment,
although logicians would
call it a truth assignment.
So an environment tells
you, given a variable,
whether or not
it's true or false.
Let's look at an
example of three
variables-- P, Q, and R.
They are true/false valued,
and I'm going to
tell you that I've
got an environment v in
which P is true and Q is true
and R is false.
So v of P was T, et cetera.
So I'm thinking of
v as a function that
maps a variable to its value.
Now, let's see how I would use
this particular environment
to figure out the value of
this composite formula whose
atomic parts are P and Q
and R, and Q again, I guess.
Let's take a look at how we
would go about figuring out
the value of this whole formula
given the values of P, Q,
and R. It's pretty
straightforward,
but the methodical way to do
it is sort of from inside out.
Let's begin by attaching the
truth values that we're given
to those particular variables.
Now, notice here that I've
got both arms of the AND
have been assigned truth
values, and they're both true.
That means I can assign
true to the conjunction
formula, the AND
formula, and I do that
by putting the T
under that AND, which
is the principal connective
of this subformula.
Now, looking back
at this Q, I've
got it's true, which means
that NOT of Q is false,
so I can put a
false under the NOT.
Now, notice I've got both
arms of this XOR are defined.
They're both false, and that
means that the XOR is false
because it's only supposed to
be true if exactly one of them
is true.
And next, I had
this true for AND.
That means that NOT of
that formula is false.
And now that I have both arms
of the OR, this one is false
and that one is
false, I can conclude
that the entire expression
is false by putting
that final truth value under
the principal connective
of the whole formula.
So that's actually an easily
defined recursive process.
I've described it
from inside out,
but if you are
programming it, you
would be doing it
recursively top-down
in order to evaluate the
truth value of a formula given
the truth values of its
constituent variables given
an environment.
Now, a basic idea about
propositional formulas
is that two of them are
equivalent if and only
if they have the same truth
values in all environments--
in all environments.
No matter what the values of
the P's and Q's and R's are,
no matter what the
truth value is,
these two formulas come out
to the same truth value,
and that's what makes
them equivalent.
Let's look at an
important example
known as De Morgan's law.
So De Morgan's
law says that if I
look at this formula, the NOT of
P or Q, the negation of P or Q,
I claim that that's
equivalent to not P and not Q,
and let's check that
with a truth table.
So here's going to be the truth
table for the first formula,
NOT P or Q, so let's write out
the four possible values for P
and Q. These are the four
possible environments,
one per row, and there is
the formula whose value
I'm trying to compute.
So we do it in the usual way.
I'm not going to repeat
the truth values of P and Q
because they're
given here, but I
can fill in the values of the
OR because I know the truth
table for OR and I discovered
that the first three
rows or subformula is true
and the last place is false
when both of them are false.
And that means that I know the
value of the whole formula,
which is the negation.
The NOT of all those values
just flips the trues and falses,
and that is the final
truth values for this NOT P
or Q in all possible
environments.
Let's do the same thing for NOT
P and NOT Q. Well, this time,
I'll fill in the values
of NOT P and NOT Q
because they're not
just repeated there.
So the NOT P is the
flip of the P column
and the NOT Q is the
flip of the Q column,
and now I can fill in
the values at the AND.
And of course, the AND
is going to be true only
when they're both true,
and otherwise it's
going to be false, and
look what I've got.
The possible truth values of
the first formula, NOT P or Q,
in all possible environments
is exactly the same
as the possible
truth values of NOT P
and NOT Q in those
corresponding environments.
The columns are
the same, and that
means these two
formulas are equivalent,
which is the proof
by truth table.
We've just examined all
possible environments
and verified that, in fact,
they get the same truth value.
This brings us to a
useful other connective
we haven't talked about
yet called if and only if.
So the value of the if
and only if connective
P if and only if Q is true,
if and only if P and Q
have the same truth value.
Now, this if and only if is
an English word that you're
supposed to understand
what it means, and that if
and only if is an
operator on truth
values that we're defining.
Since the English now can
be confusing between that
if and only if and this
if and only if, let's
disambiguate by having the
truth table for if and only if.
Here it is.
What it says is that when
both of them are true--
P if and only if Q is true--
and both of them are false--
and otherwise, it's false.
You can check that P
if and only if is true
exactly when the complement
of P XOR Q is true.
So now we come to two crucial
properties of formulas called
satisfiability and validity, and
let's examine what those are.
So a formula is
satisfiable if and only
if it's true in
some environment.
That is, it's satisfiable
if there is some way
to set the values of
the variables P and Q
to be truth values in such a
way that the formula comes out
to be true.
And a related idea is
that a formula is valid--
it's also called
a tautology-- if
and only if it's true
in all environments.
No matter what you
set the variables to,
it's going to come
out to be true.
Let's look at some examples to
solidify those two concepts.
So the formula P all by
itself is satisfiable
because it can be
true if P is true,
but it's not always true
because P might be false.
Symmetrically, NOT P
is also satisfiable
because it could be
true if P is false,
but it's not always true.
It's not valid because P
might be true, in which case
not P would be false.
A formula that's
not satisfiable,
a formula that means that
there is no truth value that
makes it true, which is the
same as saying that it's always
false, is the
formula P and NOT P.
It's probably the simplest
not satisfiable formula
or unsatisfiable formula.
So this is clearly false
because either P or NOT
P has got to be false and
the [? and ?] will then
will definitely come
out to be false.
There is no value for P that
makes this formula true.
It's unsatisfiable.
A valid formula, actually
by De Morgan's law
applied to the P and
NOT P, is P or NOT
P is going to be valid because
no matter what truth value
P has, it comes out to be true.
That is, one of P
and NOT P is true,
and therefore the OR is going to
get at least one true, exactly
one true really, and
going to come out
to be true, so this is valid.
Now we can connect up the
pieces that we've just
set up of relating
validity and equivalence.
Two formulas G and
H are equivalent
is the same as saying that
G if and only if H is valid.
So G if and only if H
comes out to be true
when G and H have
the same truth value,
and G and H are
equivalent says that they
do have the same truth value no
matter what the environment is.
So that's the same as saying
that if G and H are equivalent
no matter what the
environment is, G if and only
if H comes out to be true.
So if G and H are equivalent,
G if and only if H is valid,
and the converse argument
works the same way.
A very important problem that
comes up in multiple ways,
and we're going to examine
some of them later,
is the problem of whether
or not a formula is valid--
proving that it's valid--
and checking whether or not
a formula is satisfiable.
Now, there's a simple
way to do that.
The truth table tells it to you.
If you want to know whether
the formula is satisfiable,
you just look at
its truth table.
Try every possible environment
and see whether one of them
yields the value of true.
The problem with that
approach, which theoretically
is sound, but pragmatically
the truth table size
doubles with each
additional variable.
So with two variables,
you got four rows.
With three variables,
you got eight rows.
With four variables,
you got 16 rows,
and this very rapidly
gets out of hand
once the number of variables
gets to be moderate sized.
This is exponential growth.
It's doubling each time
you add a variable.
So really when you start
having hundreds of variables,
truth tables are
out of the question.
You just can't write them down.
They're too big, and in fact,
in modern digital circuits
when you think back about how
we designed the [? adder, ?]
if you look at what's going on
in all those different wires
corresponding to
different variables,
there are millions of those in a
typical modern digital circuit.
So truth table approach is
just not going to be workable.
It's hopeless.
Now, one of the central problems
in theoretical computer science
is the question
of whether or not
there is a way to
test for SAT that's
more efficient than this
impossible way of trying
to come up with a truth
table that's too big to fit
in the universe when
there are hundreds
and thousands of variables.
So we're interested
in the question
of is there some
other way to check
a formula for satisfiability
than exhaustively trying
to generate its whole truth
table to see if some row yields
true?
This is the abstract version
of the P equals NP problem.
So we've talked
about this before.
P equals NP?
is considered to be the
most important open problem
in theoretical computer science,
in the theory of computation,
and it's simply saying, is
there some fast or efficient way
to tell whether or not
a formula is satisfiable
that's more efficient than
the truth table approach?
Efficiency has a
technical definition,
which is that the
number of steps
grows much less
than exponentially
with the number of variables.
Let's say it grows polynomial,
like a quadratic or a cubic,
but you're trying to beat
exponential growth, which
is what ruins things quickly.
And this is an open problem.
No one knows if there
is some fast way
to check for
satisfiability or SAT.
That's the SAT problem.
By the way, very
closely related to SAT
is validity because if I wanted
to know whether a formula
G is valid-- well, valid
means that it's always true.
That means its complement,
not G, is always false,
which is the same as saying its
complement is not satisfiable.
So to check that G is
valid, all I need to do
is check that not G is
satisfiable and vice versa,
not G is not satisfiable,
if and only if G is valid.
So the point is that SAT and
valid stand and fall together.
If you had a fast way to do
one, you would very quickly
get a fast way to
do the other one.
So checking for one is just
as difficult as checking
for the other, and
we're going to examine
in subsequent lectures why
it is that this problem is
so important.